في اخر التطورات الميدانيه اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تدمير مستودع للذخيره تابع
للجيش الاوكراني في مدينه
واضافت انها احبطت 9 محاولات هجوم
اوكرانيه في محور دونيتسك من جهته اتهم
حاكم مقاطعه
القوات الاوكرانيه باستهداف المقاطعه
باكثر من 120 قذيفه وقال ان القصف ادى الى
اصابه شخصين كما قال ان مسيره اوكرانيه
اطلقت قذيفه باتجاه منطقه السوق المركزي
من منطقه شيكينو ما ادى الى اشتعال
النيران في المكان
حاكم مقاطعه فارونجا الروسيه الكسندر جوسف
افاد بان الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت
مسيرتين في المقاطعه الواقعه جنوب غربي
البلاد واشار جوسيس الى ان اسقاط
المسيرتين لم يؤدي الى اي اضرار او اصابه
الجانب الروسي في مقاطعه زفروجيا ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تنسحبت من مواقعها في
غرب مدينه ريخوف من جهه ثانيه قال موقع
العسكريه الروسيه ان القوات الروسيه تصدت
هجمات اوكرانيه جديده قرب بلده
جنوبي ضخموت واضاف الموقع ان معارك عنيفه
تدور في الجهتين الشماليه والجنوبيه من
بخموت مؤكدا ان القوات الروسيه ما زالت
تحافظ على مواقعها من دون تغيير وذكر
الموقع ان القوات الاوكرانيه تشنت هجمات
على مواقع روسيه في بلدتي رابوتينو
وجيريينكا
من دون اي تحقق اي تقدم وفقا لما افاد به
الموقع